in a day as a mid-sized person trying to  lose weight but not really trying that  hard i'm also addicted to sugar i'm a  coffee addict i don't really eat  breakfast i'll just do a keurig because  it's less calories than starbucks but  sometimes i'll get starbucks too not  even gonna lie i'll use this creamer  basically until i can't taste the coffee  anymore i can't do black coffee okay  this sandwich will change your life  pasco croissant canadian bacon spinach  artichoke dip and egg i know burnt it  i'm not a chef but it's good i swear to  god cowboy cookies these are like  spinach artichoke bites that have been  laying out all day not even alive and  okay ice cream too i'm really not trying  that hard to lose weight but i'd like  like two i'm addicted to sugar leave me  alone